hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter five
of his work the categories were
Aristotle ostensibly is discussing
substance there is a very interesting
and in some respects important side
discussion that that comes up that has
to do not with substances per se but
rather with what you could call today
linguistic or mental expressions that
relate ultimately to substances
Aristotle is using the term in in Greek
logos which which means anything from
speech itself to argument to reason but
in this in this particular case it's
better to translate it as something like
statement and we'll give some examples
of that in a bit the other term that
he's using is typically translated as
opinions and that works all right we
could also say beliefs or judgments even
assumptions assertions that we make in
our head state statements could also be
you know linguistic assertions saying
something is the case or is not the case
and the word for this is Doakes off
Doc's eye is the plural it's the same
word that we get you know we translate
sometimes in other contexts as
reputation or you know even glory or
something like that but in this case it
has to do
with what we deemed to be the case what
we what we think what we what we assume
what we tell ourselves is another way we
could we could put it so the
relationship between those things and
what Aristotle is calling and antia or
that's in the Greek contraries
contraries are things like black and
white hot and cold good and bad you know
they're there at opposite ends of a
spectrum perhaps or perhaps there's
nothing else in between definitely not
the case with black and white or hot and
cold for Aristotle no not for good or
bad either but you get the idea so why
is this coming up in the first place
well it's coming up in the course of a
discussion where Aristotle is
particularly keen to talk about the fact
that substances admit of or accept
contraries so you know for example this
book the pages are white presumably you
know these are actually made of pretty
good paper I think like acid-free and
all that but you know let this book sit
for a couple hundred years and the
colors of the pages should probably
change right if they don't have to be
very surprised although of course I
won't be around to see that in part
because the processes of change are
happening more quickly to this body that
I have right that's a process of change
as well going from young to old right
now I'm kinda in the middle point
hopefully I'll last long enough to be
old now what what is the the context
here so Aristotle has said that
substances admit of contraries that is
substances themselves can change by
losing one of the contraries and taking
on another of them so I have a prop here
that I'm gonna be using for this a chair
right this is the chair that I sit at
when I edit my videos it's red
it's wooden it's at this point in time
not broken maybe by the time that
somebody who watches this video you know
far down the line it will in fact be no
more or will have changed its color you
know right now it's a very nice this is
an Ikea piece right very nice red but
presumably over time the paint something
will happen to it
we could decide we want to repaint it
you know and make it black or white or
whatever you know you get the idea
substances themselves admit of changes
my body can be healthy right now and
then you know earlier this week I was
actually sick and maybe next week I'll
be sick again so these are the way
substances work and the way contraries
exist in substances now what aristotle
says is that it's only substances that
admit of changes like that min of
contraries where they can accept opposed
contraries not at the same time so the
same thing can't be both healthy and
sick at the same time at least not in
the same respect but it can be healthy
at one time and sick at another time and
it still remains say human being or
guinea pig or octopus or house plant
now our substances really the only thing
that admit of contraries that way
aristotle says you know somebody could
raise an objection
what could they raise the objection well
of statements and opinions notice that
it's not just any contraries that he's
going to discuss here because there's
some that just you know don't really
make that much sense unless we're
talking in a very metaphorical way all
right we can say statements seem to be
able to admit one kind of contrariness
not to be black and white or to be good
or bad or
to be hot or cold I mean we can talk
about statements in those ways but there
were again being rather metaphorical
we're not using the words in the same
sense as we would in other cases but
what about truth and falsity it
certainly seems like statements are able
to be at least some statements to be
both true and false some statements
can't some statements like a bachelor is
an unmarried male that is what we call a
tautology it's always true right you
don't even have to have bachelors or
males or anything like that it's been
defined that way and it's just always
going to be the case complex statements
that contain some sort of absurdity
which are always false would be another
case where you can't have this this sort
of change as well some sort of inherent
contradiction but it seems like there's
a lot of statements that can be both
true and false doesn't it so we're gonna
use this prop in just a moment but think
about this dr. Sadler is wearing a black
shirt and a yellow tie it's true at this
moment you probably think that it's true
while you're watching this video but you
know who knows maybe after I shoot this
I go and I change into a green shirt
with a red tie and suddenly the
statement is false so what about this he
sits in this case dr. Sadler sits I've
got a chair right here plunk it down
he sits it's a false statement right now
now it's a true statement
now it's false again and now it's true
what about when I'm halfway here well
don't worry about that too much yeah
that that's sort of like in the process
of of changing from being true to false
so if we look at it this way then it
does seem as if the statement is true at
one point and then lose
it's truth and accepts falsity as part
of that statement something that can be
predicated of the statement right
he sits is a false statement so it looks
like the statement itself is undergoing
change accepting a contrary we're
rejecting the other getting rid of that
contrary accepting the other one back in
so Aristotle says that's the wrong way
to look at it it's not the statement
itself that is changing and he says the
same thing by the way holds for opinion
because in part aristotle tends to think
of statements and opinions linguistic
expressions and their mental correlates
is essentially being the same thing
one being external one being internal so
it's not the statement that changes it's
something else
what is this something else well you
could say you know the disposition of my
body or at least you know part of my
body my posterior in relation to this
thing we call a chair or anything else
that I might happen to sit on if I were
to sit on the floor right or try to sit
on the ledge of the chalkboard probably
wouldn't work for very long there would
not be a true statement for very long
right so it's not the statement itself
that changes it's the something else
what it is that the statement is telling
us about what it's referring to and this
could hold even for imaginary things you
know Mickey Mouse is a jerk right you go
and watch the cartoon and you're like
yeah Mickey Mouse really is a jerk look
at how he treats goofy or Donald Duck
and then you know maybe you watch
another cartoon you know like you know
that Mickey's not such a bad guy after
all
our bad Mouse had bad being whatever
whatever he has bad imaginary thing it's
quite possible to say things statements
about things that don't exist so the
statement itself doesn't undergo the
change
what does undergo the change in this
case for example a substance my
body in relation to the chair aristotle
will go on and say nothing can actually
change statements or opinions that's a
weird thing to say that i imagine
probably throws a few readers off he
doesn't mean that in the sense of well
we never change our minds about things
so that if i you know think that this is
a red chair and then I find out that I
actually have red-green color blindness
and it's it's really a green chair and
somebody demonstrates that to me say by
showing me the spectra of the light
waves or something along those lines
it's not that I wouldn't possibly change
my my opinion about it but when we say
change my opinion we don't mean that I'm
actually changing that opinion itself we
you know in in its what it is to be an
opinion we're saying that I get rid of
that opinion and add a different one in
its place so it's a little bit of an
imprecise way of talking about things if
we were and it's probably easier to
think about this in terms of statements
if we were to change a statement and say
this is a red chair and then change the
statement to this as a green share what
we've actually done is created a new
different statement we haven't changed
the original statement we've just taken
that one off the table that one is still
what it is this is a red chair so we
don't change statements or opinions in
themselves as the statement or opinion
that they are you might say well what
about when we clarify we say this is a
red chair as it appears to me that's a
different statement again that's not the
same thing as the original statement so
there's really two important upshots of
this one is that as it turns out
statements and opinions are not a
counterexample to Aristotle's
position that it's only substances that
that admit of contraries in the way that
they do and the other thing is well we
know something now a little bit more at
least about how Aristotle thinks about
it about truth and falsity as things
that can be predicated of opinions or
statements they don't work quite the
same way as red and green or spicy and
sour or although those aren't actually
opposites right so but you get the idea
good and bad hot and cold tall and short
any any of these these sorts of things
truth and falsity work in a somewhat
different way and require some reference
to the relationship between linguistic
or mental things and things pragma
Affairs out there in reality or at least
imagined out there in reality